avanzamos con nuestra agenda de temas en
directo américa de france 24 y para eso
está en el estudio rosa pérez además de
con toda la información de los
periódicos y los portales de internet
rosa vamos a comenzar con esta noticia
the review of books the london review of
books sobre este turismo que se está
dando hasta las fronteras con ucrania
buenos dias angela exactamente esta es
una crónica de ada wordsworth ella es
intérprete voluntaria en la frontera de
ucrania con polonia y ayuda a las
personas que huyen de la guerra de
ucrania pues a entender un poco pues
polonia un poco el funcionamiento de los
transportes no la logística comunicarse
con las autoridades bien ella describe
un poco el ambiente en esta ciudad de
juiz que es donde llegan la mayoría de
refugiados ucranianos no para cuando
entran en polonia ella explica que al
margen de todas las personas que están
huyendo de la invasión rusa también
llegan ahí muchos estadounidenses y
europeos de europa occidental explica
con sus camionetas
tiendas coloridas con sus peleles y que
están ahí tocando música dice o
regalando dulces o peluches a niños que
cito textualmente no se han podido lavar
los dientes en días y no pueden cargar
más que las pocas pertenencias que han
podido rescatar de sus hogares dice
también hay grupos evangelistas
estadounidenses que reparten postales
con la palabra del señor con arco iris y
castillos dice hay un alemán tocando el
piano un francés haciendo crepes ella
llega a compararlo como decías al
principio del programa con el festival
glastonbury este festiva con macro
festival de música británico no dice
podría aparecer esto si dejas pues si
das la espalda a las personas refugiadas
dice que a ella vienen precisamente
todas las personas de habla inglesa para
ver un poco en lo que pueden ayudar pero
que ella cuando constata rápidamente que
no hablan ni ucraniano ni polaco ni ruso
y que muchos de ellos tampoco tienen
carro particular se pregunta pues que
pueden aportar porque no han decidido
dar el dinero que les ha costado el
trayecto directamente en lugar de
desplazarse hasta la frontera y acaba
con algunos ejemplos históricos no para
constatar que el turismo de guerra
tampoco es una novedad pues mire cada
cual da de lo que puede pero poniéndolo
todo en contexto pues habría que revisar
la que hay cosas que se salen
completamente digamos de los cabales por
supuesto angela y también de hecho
critica a los periodistas que están ahí
a los bloggers y dice que no pierden la
ocasión de fotografiar a cualquier niño
llorando no hay que le dicen a ella pues
que no podían no estar ahí mire qué
vergüenza y vamos a seguir hablando un
poco más del tema el alcalde de
melitópol y quien estuvo secuestrado por
el ejército ruso habló en la televisión
francesa y dijo que sufrió violencia
psicológica cuéntenos eso es y banfield
ahora el alcalde de melitópol que fue
liberado tras cinco días de cautiverio
como decías está dando un recorrido por
europa explicando la situación en
ucrania y particularmente lo que él
vivió en estos cinco días de cautiverio
a manos del ejército ruso él dijo que
particularmente no sufrió violencia
física pero sí psicológica que sin
embargo oía gritos de lo que él atribuyó
a torturas
de al lado pero sobre todo destaca que
los soldados rusos tenían muy integrado
este discurso de la necesidad de
desmasificar ucrania bueno y vamos a
hablar de los portadores de limón schuss
le figaro y libération
exactamente nos quedamos en francia
después de comentar esta entrevista que
tuvo lugar en la televisión francesa bfm
nos fijamos en los periódicos franceses
que hoy ya empiezan a destacar la
contienda electoral a diferencia de la
semana pasada que todavía estaba muy
relegado este tema empezamos por lo mont
que destaca el programa de marín le pen
que decía detrás de la normalización un
programa de extrema derecha y es que
ciertamente no las los discursos de
extrema derecha han entrado de una forma
muy mainstream no en el debate electoral
en francia por otro lado le figaro dice
cobit ucrania una elección ahogada por
las crisis y terminamos con liberación
que dice hacer mckinsey cueste lo que
cueste liberación siempre hace estos
juegos de palabras no alquilan cut cual
también puede significar pues se desliza
y es que hacer relación a este asunto
que podría eclipsar un poco el mandato
de macrón y es lo que ha descrito un
informe del senado francés como un
recurso masivo a estas consultorías
privadas que dan pues esos consejos
tanto a organismos privados como
públicos sobre cómo gestionar ciertos
temas que cuestan pues una millonada y
que durante el mandato de macrón pues el
estado ha hecho pues es o no un uso
masivo de este tipo de pues el servicio
y que pues ahora está saliendo a la luz
sobre todo en relación con la gestión de
la vacunación contra el commit 19 y nos
quedamos pues con este tema para ver
pues las viñetas que hemos seleccionado
de un par de medios franceses muy bien
rosas y vea y así quería hablarle porque
algo que me gusta particularmente de
cuando los puedo acompañar en directo
américa es estas secciones de las
caricaturas que usted nos presenta y
bueno pues cuéntenos de qué se trata
exactamente aquí tenemos un primer
dibujo de pierrick en mediapart que pues
hace referencia a este mismo tema no el
recurso es todas estas consejerías el
gobierno busca cómo puedes desinflar
calmar un poco la polémica y pues
bastante cómico que es macrón pidiendo
pues a los consejeros de estas
consultorías privadas precisamente
alguna idea para ayudarse a sí mismos no
a algún consejo alguna recomendación y
por otro lado tenemos un dibujo de coco
en liberación que dibuja a la candidata
de los republicanos de la derecha
conservadora valérie pécresse
lamentándose porque pues sarkozy también
el ex presidente de también este partido
los republicanos pues no le está
apoyando mire y muy rápidamente un
análisis de the gardian sobre el estado
de la izquierda en francia a propósito
de nuestro primer invitado del día que
ya viene exacto muy rápidamente the
gardian pues habla del hundimiento no
del partido socialista de hecho la
izquierda está hoy en día más bien a
manos de jean luc menciones de la
francia insumisa y se plantea qué pueden
hacer los votantes tradicionales del
partido socialista para que esté
presente la izquierda en el segundo pues
en la segunda vuelta pero es que hemos
destacado que al yazira ya hablaba de
esta caída de la izquierda con un título
idéntico what's left of the friends left
que queda de la izquierda francesa y en
2 15 tras unas elecciones regionales que
también ganó la derecha